you may have heard the DDF or in your
computers have transfers of well over 20
gigabytes a second but did you know that
the l1 cache in your seat views have
transfer eighths of up to 200 gigabytes
a second wait a minute what even disk
cache what does it do and why do you
need it
[Music]
welcome to hari sadhus CPU cache is a
type of cache that the computer
processor uses to access data and
programs much more quickly than to the
main Ram since the cache is embedded
directly onto your processor or very
close to it it is much more faster than
Ram
generally CPU cache is very small and
does not exceed a handful of megabytes
and as a result it only stores the most
frequently used data and programs all it
does is make copies of the most
frequently used ram locations to further
improve transfer rates CPU cache is
generally made up of SRAM as opposed to
DRAM which mostly makes a brand kits if
you want an in-depth explanation of the
to it make sure to check out my dedicate
a video on ramp but as a quick overview
DRAM or dynamic random-access memory is
a ram that needs to be consistently
refreshed for it to store data however
DRAM is able to store one bit of data
for every transistor and scram on the
other hand does not need to be
consistently refreshed
however as friend request several
transistors just to store one bit of
data consequently SRAM is much faster
but also much more expensive due to the
extra size due to the extra cost is only
used as small amounts in places like CPU
cache now when you buy your CPU you may
remember reading on a spec sheet about
the foster heavy l1 l2 and l3 cache all
of this is is memory that operates at
different speeds and have different
capacities
l1 is the fast memory but generally it
also has a smallest capacity so only
stores the most frequently used data the
next most frequently used data is stored
in l2 cache which is a bit slower but
generally also allowed for your capacity
and the same thing goes for l3 and even
Al for cache differs
has it finally once all these memories
are exhausted the information is then
stored onto the main Ram multi-core
chips typically have varying amounts of
each of these types of CPU cache for
example it is preferred for each court
have its own l1 cache in order to reduce
latency as a result a common octa-core
processor may have an l1 cache for each
core and intermediate all to cache for
each pair of course and in just one l3
cache for the core processor right now
l4 cache is pretty uncommon where you
can find on some of Intel CPUs with
onboard
edie Ram at this point in time the
benefits of l4 cash
simply don't outweigh the extra costs
associated with it
nowadays most CPUs have at least three
different types of cache which are
instruction cache data cache and TLB or
translational look aside buffer cache
instruction cache is used to speed up
executable instruction fetch while data
cache is used to speed up data fetch and
data store data cache is typically was
organized into multiple levels of
hierarchy which are l1 l2 and l3 cache
finally TLB cache is used to speed up
virtual to physical address translation
for both executable instructions and
data so hopefully by now you understand
what CPU cache is what it does and why
you're needed on top of this you should
know about the premium levels of cache
and what the three different types of
cats accomplish so next time you're
shopping for CPU hopefully you will have
a better understanding of what the spec
sheet is talking about so time is
something important about CPU cache and
what computer concept or hardware
concept would you like me to cover next
make your comment down below also if you
guys liked this video that makes you
drop a like and consider subscribing if
you would like to see more videos just
like this one but until then I'm Hari
and I'll see you guys on the next one
[Music]
[Applause]